[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de si on parlait sport l'émission
à ne surtout pas manquer sur tv78 si
vous êtes un passionné de sport local
aujourd'hui c'est une émission un peu
spécial on est tous sur notre 31 pour
les fêtes présentation en musique de la
dream team on commence à ma droite
musique c'est un véritable guerrier un
guerrier toujours très élégant un
mélange entre George clouny et Russell
crro aujourd'hui il est plutôt George
clownet tellement il est élégant pour
cette émission notre gladiateur du Rugby
Club de Versailles Pierre Chevalier est
avec nous pendant 1 heure comment
allez-vous oh oh oh for et bonheur à
tous très très bien dans cette magie de
Noël qui s'annonce
effectivement c'est magnifique c'est
fait très très très très heureux de
participer sur un tel plateau tellement
joli à cette émission spéciale Noël
mention spéciale pour votre petit gilet
rouge voilà le gilet voilà le Père Noël
costume de chez wish nickel on continue
à gauche musique connaissez sa musique
c'est un Italien un vrai et comme tout
italien qui se respecte il est très
classe son petit mais magnifique village
diamanté dans le sud fier de lu et la
fierté des siens notre italien lover
grgory canal de tv78 est avec nous
pendant une heure salut Michel salut pi
salut à tous Comment allez-vous très
bien bah ravi de passer à table avec les
amis de la team si on parle sport pour
cette émission juste avant les fêtes de
fin d'année on est paré pour affronter
cette période on va parler de sport
avant de passer vraiment à table pour
déguster de bon ma c'est un sport aussi
sport très joli nœud papillon grgor je
signaler le comme la squadraour mon
équipe de cœur ça on l'oublie pas ça on
l'oublie pas du côté de Gregory allez on
repasse de l'autre côté musique cette
année 2023 a été son année dans cette
émission il est aujourd'hui un titulaire
indiscutable il est habillé en pull de
Noël aujourd'hui je crois savoir qu'il a
acheté en lut je crois savoir qu'il a
acheté spécialement ses vêtement pour
l'occasion Philippe volac responsable
sponsoring chez Orange en île- de France
c'est avec nous pendant 1 heure bonour
bonjour à tous C'est B oui lutin parce
que je travaille beaucoup he il faut que
j'aille le Père Noël il faut que je
soigne les rennes du père Noël et j'ai
beaucoup de travail j'ai pas eu le temps
de me changer donc c'est pour ça que
voilà que vous faites que travailler dis
donc travailler et vous avez travaillé
l'émission j'espère oui beoup j'ai eu le
temps aussi ouais entre deux paquets
cadeaux j'ai eu le temps de ouis on peut
vous garder ou pas pour faire décor dans
les dans sur ce
plateauémission pe d'accord ok on verra
ça après l'émission on termine de
l'autre côté musique mesdames et
messieurs c'était encore la superst de
cette année 2023 sur ce plateau il comp
faire encore mieux en 2024 c'est une lég
vies analyses sont toujours précis punch
traversent les écrans de télévision Jean
Miss exentraîneur de plaisirentraîneur
de rugby est avec nous pendant une heure
magnifique lunette vous m'avez un peu
surpris Jean et ben bonjour à tous
Comment allez-vous très heureux d'être
parmi vous aujourd'hui pour cette
dernière émission de
l'année vous allez faire cette émission
toute l'émission avec ces lunettes non
je pense pas parce que elles me font mal
aux yeux c'est pas les bonbes ver
bon vous l'aurez compris he il y a une
bonne ambiance hein sur cette sur sur
plateau pendant pour cette émission ceci
on parler sport avant de passer au
programme de l'émission on va parler
football et du FC Versailles après avoir
écarté début novembre Laurent perelade
le FCV depuis placé sur le banc
l'entraîneur adjoint grégoryi Vignal
après deux victoires en deux matchs le
club a confirmé l'ancien défenseur comme
entraîneur principal par biais d'un
communiqué depuis les joueurs de
greégory vigal on réussi à faire match
nul ce lundi 18 décembre contre le
leader le Red St le score de partout
dans un match spectaculaire la question
sur cette thématique Versailles a-t-il
pris la bonne décision les instances
bien sûr Mel on était tellement pressé
de faire cette émission on a même pas
les petites raquette je vous propose
aller les chercher allez-y
allez-yzy on va commencer
déjà on a pas no traditionnelle raquette
alors bah on va faire juste un tour de
table déjà alors vers a-t-il pris la
bonne décision euh Pierre
Chevalier alors pour vous oui oui par
oui on on parler la dernière fois de de
la partie merci Grégor hein comme vous
pouvez le voir
Grégor vivante également
assistant ce plateau il est au four et
au moulin on parlait on parlait la
dernière fois de de choc psychologique
euh forcé de constater que il devait y
avoir dans le
vestiaire un problème un sujet avec avec
Laurent Perlade le choc psychologique
dont on parlait finalement a été là
positif on disait que c'était une fois
sur deux en gros dans les équipes de
sport collectif et là là il faut il faut
se rendre à l'évidence que le choc
psychologique a fonctionné et que pour
l'instant Grégory vigal fait les bons
choix humains sportifs le vestiaire
semble le suivre et je pense qu'on va
reparler en détail de notamment du match
de lundi dernier on se on se disait
aussi que c'était que c'était
ce match contre le Red Star qui était un
vrai test grandendeur nature pour la
suite de la saison et pour savoir
exactement où où Versailles en est là on
est sur une base de de 9e place
actuellement avec un match en retard
donc ventrreemou peut-être que les
objectifs sont revus pour l'instant à la
baisse mais en tout cas sur les TR
quatre derniers matchs c'est un c'est
c'est plutôt une réussite donc j'aurais
tendance à dire que que la décision la
décision a été bonne pour forcer un peu
le destinor allezin vous êtes comme à la
maison ici he jeis passé devant les
caméras désolé pour le réalisateur de
cette émission Nathan que je salue bien
sûr euh merci en tout cas d'avoir
apportter ces petites raquettes comme je
précise à chaque
fois oui et rouge non comme d'habitude
euh Grégor qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
justement de l'intronisation de Grégory
vigal alors c'est vrai que moi alors
forcément avec la forme actuelle moi je
mets plutôt oui pour la bonne décision
ça semble être une bonne décision même
s'il faut attendre je pense dans dans la
duré là il y a quand même eu deux
résultats positifs pour Versailles même
un troème puisque le match nul face au
Red Star qui est qui est leader c'est
une performance à mon sens de de de très
très bonnes factures pour les
Versaillais c'est vrai que j'avais fait
une envolée sur on laisse pas assez de
temps à l'entraîneur alors c'était plus
une envolée on va dire générale c'est
vrai que dans le monde du sport en
général on parlait le la dernière fois
du fusible bah qu'on utilise quand il y
a des mauvais résultats c'est souvent
malheureusement l'entraîneur qui trinque
moi je disais qu'on avait pas forcément
laissé sa chance totalement sa chance à
à Laurent Perlade après c'est vrai
qu'avec le choc psychologique un peu vos
propos ou pas vu les résultats bah
j'attends de voir quand même sur la
durée mais là on a quand même trois
résultats on va dire positif pour le FCV
deux victoires et et un match nul donc
ça semble prédire et ça semble dire
qu'il y a peut-être quelque chose qui s
décoincé il y a peut-être un déclic euh
effectivement en coulisse peut-être que
les relations pas beau fixe entre les
joueurs et Lorent Perl ets que greégory
vigal incarne un peu mieux ce ce rôle de
coach au sein du FCV on voit le
classement c'est quand même très serré
et Versailles peut peut-être viser un
podium peut-être en en en fin de saison
ils sont à 7 points euh de la 2uxe place
en rappelant il faut rappeler aussi
qu'ils ont un match en moins puisque le
match face à Orléan euh qui était juste
avant celui face au Red Star a été
reporté mais à contrario si on regarde
ils sont aussi pas loin de cette 13e
place ils sont à qu points de la 13e
place on rappelle qu'il y a six
descentes donc voilà ça dépend si on
voit le verre à moitié vide ou à moitié
plein en tout cas il y a une bonne
dynamique du côté de versaill depuis
l'intronisation de Grégory vigal lutin
Philippe volac qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez déjà Greg Leit un macaron parce
qu'il a dit sur la durée donc il a leoit
un
macaron non j'ai pour avoir regardé le
le match lundi soir j'ai trouvé deux
très belles équipes et même versaill l'a
dit Versailles quand ils ont interviewé
à la fin du match ils ont dit que
c'était vraiment de deux très belles
équipes l'entraîneur je trouve qu'il est
atypique he il a fait il a fait
l'entraîneur vigal il est parce que il a
il a comment je dire il a fait quand
même 12 clubs 12 clubs qu'il a fait il
joué dans 12 clubs et pratiquement
toujours comme remplaçant donc il a il a
il voit ce que c'est d'être remplaçant
ou comment on dit pas remplaçant ou
presque pas jouer et je trouve que c'est
pas mal je veux dire et il a fait aussi
énormément de clubs aussi il a commencé
en plus avec Houlier c'est ça avec
Houlier qu'il a commencé en tant
qu'entraîneur en 2016 et je trouve que
non je trouve qu'il a c'est bien je
trouve ouais moi je bon j'étais j'avais
dit que j'étais optimiste et je reste je
reste en étant en étant optimiste sur
déjà les matchs qu'on a vu lundi soir
avec trois superbes buts c'est vrai
trois superbes buts et il y avait quand
même de l'ambiance bon un peu le souci
de qui sont arrivés presque à la
mi-temps il y en a beaucoup donc il a
encore eu un souci de voilà à l'entrée
mais bon il va falloir corriger mais je
trouve qu'il en plus il y avait du monde
c'était on on a justement les quelques
images vous faites une petite transition
Grégory était sur place comment vous
avez vécu cette soirée je fais partie de
voilà on va dire je sais pas si on peut
appeler ça des victimes en tout cas de
ces personnes qui n'ont pas pu assister
à la première mi-temps du match il en a
même qui ont loupé les toutes premières
minutes de la 2ème mi-temps alors moi ma
chance c'est que je suis rentré à peu
près la 42e minute donc j'ai vu tous les
buts du match puisque tous les buts ont
été inscrits entre la 44e et la 4 avant
fait c'est pour ça bah on arrivé quand
même ouais 20 minutes avant moi j'is
déjà vu peêtre c'est ça mais j'avais vu
plusieurs matchs à jamboin et il était
assez facile de rentrer là visiblement
c'était plus compliqué 1500 personnes
qui attendez dehors alors ce qui a été
dit sur différents articles de presse
c'est que les machines qui servaient à
scanner les billets au bout d'un moment
n'ont plus fonctionner moi pour avoir
été sur place j'ai observé aussi
d'autres dysfonctionnements euh
peut-être pas assez d'agents de sécurité
il y avait deux agents pour les fouille
peut-être trois quatre agents pour
vérifier les billets quand la la machine
le scanner ne fonctionnait plus donc on
on parle quand même de moins de 10
personnes pour un match qui était censé
quand même accueillir 8000 personnes
alors j'ai pu moi échanger avec euh euh
avec euh Fabien Lazar j'ai eu un trou de
mémoire le directeur général du club via
les réseaux sociaux en lui demandant
voilà en lui précisant pourquoi enfin en
lui demandant pourquoi on lui demandant
des explications et il m'a dit que il ne
s'attendait pas à un tel engouement un
engouement de dernière minute beaucoup
de personnes ont pris leur place le jour
même ou quelques jours quelques jours
avant et par rapport à d'autres matchs
de Versailles il y a eu moins de nocho
c'estàd des nocho c'est tout simplement
des spectateurs qui prennent leur
billets qui finalement ne se présentent
pas le jour J pour le match là
finalement tout tout le monde est venu
et donc il m'a confirmé que ils allaient
réfléchir en interne analyser toutes les
les causes pour que cette situation ne
se reproduise pas parce que comme je
vous le disais il y a quand même des
gens il y a au moins une centaine une
bonne centaine de personnes qui n'ont
même pas vu les buts inscrits dans cette
rencontre les quatre buts une mauvaise
anticipation pour pour résumer peut-être
de l'gation ceil a semblé dire il a il
n'avait pas mesuré l'engouement autour
de ce match quand même face au leader du
FC Versailles Pierre Chevalier je je
pense qu'il a il y a ça remet un coup de
projecteur sur les problèmes les
problèmes du FC Versailles à domicile je
mets des gros gros guillemets parce
qu'on est dans une enceinte qui peut qui
peut accueillir qui peut accueillir
20000 20000 personnes pour le Stade
Français Paris et et et en fait on n pas
l'habitude en gros le le FCV son
organisation sa
communication n'a pas l'habitude et
alors qu'on reçoit le leader on reçoit
même si même si même si c'est à jamboin
on reçoit le leader avec avec avec la
tête d'affich c'est un peu un derby
derby plus donc Habib bil il y a il y a
il y a il a il y a vraiment pas mal de
choses qui tournent autour de ce match
là qui était annoncé comme en plus un
vrai test contre contre le le leader du
championnat et on et on se trouve sur
sur des problèmes de logistique et
d'organisation c'est effectivement les
scan les les scanettes de de de billets
qui qui ne marchaient pas c'est pas
comme s'ils avaient pas eu le choix dans
la date sur le sur le sur le jour lundi
soir annoncé de longues dates et et a
priori il manque il manque une grosse
organisation en fait d'un vrai match de
national donc soit versaill n'a plus
l'habitude ou ou ne l'a jamais eu sur
sur le fait de de recevoir des grosses
affiches à domicile d'ailleurs je l'ai
pas précisé je pense que l'un des
problèmes aussi c'est qu'il y avait un
seul point d'accès pour la tribune qui
est du côté du Parc des Princes qui est
la tribune principale où on avait les
billets on va dire les plus attractifs à
une à une somme de 10 € il y avait une
seule entrée pour faire entrer quasiment
la l'ensemble la quasi majorité des 8000
spectateur qui était attendu sur C plus
grosse influence quoi plus grosse
influence Jean on va peut-être revenir
sur grégoryi vigal vous qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez du fait soit ah vous
voulez
rebondir non non oui oui qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous de Grégor vigal
nouvel entraîneur du coup du du FC
Versailles et ben c'est très bien je dis
que c'est très bien parce que Ben
visiblement visiblement le problème
était venait de l'Anci entraîneur qui
avait un relationn quand on voit
quandation il y a que le résultat
sportif qui qui parle euh force de
reconnaître aujourd'hui que trois trois
bons résultats sur trois on peut pas on
on peut pas les mettre de côté ce n'est
pas possible et et là on ne peut que
constater heureusement tant mieux que il
y avait un problème relationnel entre
l'ancien entraîneur et et le vestiaire
c'est sûr puisque là finalement ben on
fait plus que le vestiaire fait plus
confiance à à Vignal qui ne le faisait à
son à à son ancien entraîneur donc bon
c'est c'est très bien c'est très bien au
moins au moins ça montre que Ben le
choix a été fait et le bon choix été a
été fait c'était c'était vraiment pour
une fois peut-être un problème
d'entraîneur alors je veux pas dire que
l'entraîneur n'est pas bon c'est
simplement que le message ne passait pas
avec avec les joueurs ça arrive
peut-être que voilà il n'a pas il n'a
pas réussi à mettre en place quelque
chose et peut-être qu'il n'avait pas la
communication nécessaire pour le mettre
en place et donc bonne chance et
j'espère que ça va continuer comme ça
puce qu'en plus c'était pas non plus un
étranger le le l'entraîneur il était
déjà au club c'était l'entraîur à joint
donc il était déjà connu des joueurs et
je pense que il est nouveau mais nouveau
sansêtre nouveau vraent n il était déjà
là il était déjà arrivé il était déjà en
place il participer déjà il a simplement
changé de de statut il a pris les
reennes et puis ça marche bien et tant
mieux et tant mieux et il est confirmé
jusqu'à la fin de la saison donc à voir
en fin de saison si ça marche il va
sûrement rester et peut-être qu'il va
partir si ça ne marche mais de toute
façon euh on on peut pas on ne peut pas
dire aujourd'hui euh que ce n'est pas
bon parce que lui il a des résultats
donc s'il a des résultats c'est que
c'est bon et c'est favorable je voulais
juste dire un petit truc quand même
parce que je trouve regrettable quand
même les les incidents qui qui se sont
passés pour pour pour pour l'accueil des
spectateurs parce qu'on se plaint depuis
longtemps ici Ben qui manque de de de de
de spectateurs parce que parce que c'est
pas à Versailles parce que c'est
décentralisé c'est à jamboin là pour une
fois où il y avait du monde ils se sont
loupés moi je dis qu'ils se sont loupés
et l'organisateur les l'organisation et
les organisateurs ont be se trouver des
excuses pour moi que ce soit le choix
dans la date ou ou ou les les beipers
qui marchaient pas ou le nombre mais
c'est ils se sont plantés pour moi ils
se sont planté et c'est regrettable
parce que il y a quand même une une
grande partie des spectateurs qui qui
vont peut-être bah dire moi je viens
plus moi si c'est pour voir une mi-temps
ou 30 minutes ou pas du tout ben là je
pense que c'est un peu dommage parce que
c'était peut-être le le moyen de faire
venir des gens au stade et de de de de
de fidéliser des supporters à jambouin
alors qu'on sait que c'est pas av
opération marketing non réussit ah tout
à fait pour moi oui
pierre pour clore le tenter de clore le
sujet sur Grégory vigal ça semblerait
pouvoir montrer que malgré une
expérience dans le football dans le
football professionnel comme l'avit
Perlade avec Rodez en même en Ligue 2
par jusqu'à jusqu'à la Ligue 2 le
l'humain compte plus et qu'à priori
Grégory vigal en arrivant d'abord comme
adjoint et puis après comme entraîneur
en chef à trouvé les clés les clés
humaines humaines et affective et
sportive avec son vestire Grégory juste
pour moi c'est le déclic Grégory vigal
mais à la base moi je reste persuadé
qu'il y avait quand même un groupe de
qualité je l'ai vu j'ai pu le voir de
nouveau face au Red Star où certes il y
a eu deux partout face au leader mais on
est même presque frustré parce que
Versailles est à 11 contre 10 il y a une
expulsion du côté du Redstar à une barre
transversale en en 2è période moi
j'étais même presque frustré de pas voir
une victoire
face au Red mais ça confirma une chose
et ce qui se tram aussi depuis le début
de la saison on a quand même un groupe à
la base de qualité qui est certes jeune
qui a été renouvelé pour la grande
majorité à l'intersaison mais voilà
confirme voilà et qui confirme quand
même qu' il y a des qualités il y a du
répondant dans cet effectif très
rapidement je fais un tour de table qui
voit Versailles en Ligue 2 Grégory non
pas cette saison Jean non pas cette
saison pas cette saison Philippe et vous
non plus donc non pour tout le monde
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de box et de la défaite de
Tony Yoka livlinois Grégory canal nous
donnera aussi son envolet avec le fameux
sportif yvelinois de l'année 2023 il y
aura du niveau à cette année on verra un
peu plus tard mais avant de parler de
ces thème on va continuer à parler
[Musique]
football on va donc continuer par du
football on va parler du PSG le club qui
a pour camp de base le camp
d'entraînement de poissie dans les ivin
va jouer les 8è de finale de la Ligue
des Champions les coéquipiers de Kyan
Mbappé ont terminé 2e de leur pou
derrière le Borussia Dortmund et devant
le Milan AC Newcastle mais c'était quand
même très chaud he jusqu'à la dernière
seconde ils ont failli se faire éliminé
en 8e de finale le PSG jouera contre la
Real sociedade 6e de Liga la question
sur cette thématique le bilan du PSG sur
cette première partie de la Ligue des
Champions est-il positif vous votez
messieurs
vous êtes partager Grégory partager Jean
pas positif pour vous Philippe et
positif pour vous pierref un petit duel
entre Philippe et Pierre alors Philippe
pourquoitin non je trouve que c'est pas
pas possible même si on disait que
c'était le groupe de la mort déjà c'est
le groupe où il y a le moins de points
que les premiers ont le MO moins de
point il y a eu que deux victoires deux
victoires c'est quand même pas c'est
quand même pas beaucoup le le regret je
pense que c'est Newcastle à domicile où
PSG devait gagner devait gagner a eu 30
et quelques tirs et ça a fait 11 et
encore on y échappe c'est grâce à ça au
penalty à la dernière seconde que qu'on
se qualifie bon après faut pas non plus
quand il se qualifiaent les autres
années avec beaucoup de points d'avance
il se plantaient en 8e je me dis voilà
je veux
dire le tirage ben on on on voulait
celui-là bon après c'est pas sûr on n'
pas gagné non plus hein mais c'est CELI
qu'on voulait la Real sociédad mais
voilà donc peut-être que Kilian fera
moins la tête parce que à la fin du
match qu nmoun il faisait vraiment la
tête pour essayer de marquer un deuxième
but et être premier et voilà et en
tirant là real sociad si ça avait été
sur on avait été premier peut-être qu'on
aurait tiré lesbzig qui était encore
plus gros donc voilà donc je pense
qu'ils ont voilà ils ont eu un bon
tirage aussi après on a toujours dit
depuis le début he c'était le groupe de
la mort ça allait jouer les Quates
pouvaient se se qualifier dans les deux
premiers et voilà donc c'est déjà bien
d'être 2è on a un bon tirage dormoun
aussi a eu un bon tirage aussi
relativement avec psven mais voilà je
trouve
que c'est non non non non non non c'est
pas positif je dis par rapport à ce qui
le nombre de points je dis et les que
les deux deux victoires en que deux
victoires quand même donc c'est par
rapport à ça que c'est pas que c'est pas
positif en terme de Po en tout cas en
terme de points pierre qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez alors tout de suite une
une un point le PSG doit se qualifier en
8e de finale tout tout toutes les
saisons c'est un devoir c'est une
habitude maintenant et c'est un devoir
donc ça on va dire job donne maintenant
c'est sur la manière là là où je trouve
je trouve que c'est positif il y a deux
raisons la
première Philippe l'a rappelé c'est que
c'était un groupe relevé compliqué
relevé pouit mettre peut-être peut-être
Newcastle un petit peu à part par
rapport aux trois autres gros et encore
on a vu d'ailleurs les résultats l'ont
prouvé que c'était c'était pas forcément
une si petite équipe que ça et donc il
fallait sortir il fallait sortir de ce
groupe là premier ou 2uxè et pour
pouvoir espérer espérer faire faire
mieux que les années précédentes parce
que c'est là c'est là où je trouve que
c'est positif c'est que je trouve le PSG
cette saison dans un costume de
besogneux c'estàdire que c'est beaucoup
moins clinquant que les années que les
années précédentes mais je trouve ça
beaucoup plus homogène euh on a on a
fait le ménage de ces stars qui attiré
la lumière sans pour autant sans pour
autant tirer au but et marquer et et et
qualifier le PSG ce ce pourquoi ils
avaient été pour parti recruté comme
Neymar par exemple pour ne citer que lui
je trouve autour de de luouis Enrique et
cette méthode là justement qui qui est
la sienne de de de de de mettre tout le
monde au travail assez prometteuse pour
7 saison et sur cette phase de poule là
où je trouve que le bilan est positif
c'est
que malgré malgré des des matchs nuls
qui aurait pu qui aurait mérité mieux
notamment notamment
newcassle le PSG se qualifie a de la
chance au au tirage pour une fois reste
à voir si après au grattage ça sera ça
sera le cas pour les 8e et pour aller
plus loin voire au bout et et je et et
la la dernière chose c'est c'est de se
dire que là on est on est on n'est pas
favoris habituellement c'était la grosse
armada du PSG qui se qualifia en 8e de
finale qui allait rouler sur tout le
monde ça n'est jamais arrivé et là là je
trouve je trouve le groupe concentré je
trouve le groupe homogène euh ce ce
sortant avec avec du mal de cette de
cette phase de poule donc donc bilan
positif et maintenant c'est mettre la
pièce sur sur un sur un parcours que
l'on souhaite que l'on souhaite inédit
pour le PSG en Ligue des Champions avec
une avec la finale et et et voir voir la
coupe aux grandes oreilles Grégory qui
vous a convaincu alors moi je disais
plutôt mitigé plutôt mitigé moi je
dirais quand même plutôt déçu de cette
première phase de pool du du PSG alors
oui le positif effectivement c'est qu'il
a une nouvelle qualification pour le
parissgermain mais Pierre l'a rappelé
c'est presque une normalité pour
l'équipe du parissaggermain avec le
budget qui est mis chaque année sur la
table pour briller sur la scène
européenne moi je pense qu'il y a plus
de négatif dans dans cette phase de
poule alors pour plusieurs raisons déjà
le PSG vraiment aller chercher sa
qualification au forceps il a fallu
attendre la dernière journée et une
victoire inespérée de l'AC Milan à
Newcastle pour valider définitivement le
le billet du PSG si Newcastle s'imposait
face à Milan c'est Newcastle qui se
qualifiait avec avec Dortmund donc une
qualification obtenue vraiment au
forceps et puis on a alé é éiminé
pendant 10 15 minutes hein je pense ça
ça a duré 10 15 minutes après l'ASS
Milan a égalisé et a même réussi à à
gagner un peu contre toute attente
assim000ans peut-être sur cette phase de
poouol moi je trouvais que c'était
l'équipe sur le papier qui avait
peut-être le moins d'arguments pour
aller en 8e de finale au final ils
réussissent à se qualifier pour l'Europa
League voilà il termine TR but ça jou
effectivement à quelques buts on
alternait le bon et le très médiocre
aussi pour le PSG sur cette phase de
pooule des victoires clinquantes et
derrière le PSG qui est capable de
perdre 41 face à Newcastle qui est
capable d'aller perdre à saniro face
face à ass Milan donc on a eu aussi
beaucoup de de déception et je trouve
moi que le PSG sort avec des
incertitudes de ce ce groupe des
incertitude individuelle on a vu un
Colom on a vu un Ousman Dembélé pas
forcément à leur avantage sur cette
phase de poolle de la Ligue des
Champions on a vu un Kylian Mbappé agacé
un peu boutur je sais pas dans quel état
on va le retrouver pour il n pas célbré
son dernier but lors du dernier match
contre Lille et voilà pour citer aussi
une individualité parce que moi je le
suis avec plus d'attention c'est Gian
Luigi donaruma on se demande même quand
Dona Roma ne va va va faire un match
sans erreur on a l'impression que en
Ligue des Champions il alterne alors il
fait de superbes parade mais il est
aussi capable de faire des des petites
boulettes qui peuvent coûter cher au
final au PSG donc le positif voilà bon
j'ai donné beaucoup de négatif c'est la
qualification c'est peut-être ce tirage
sur le papier abordable pour le
parissgermain mais à mon avis le PSG
sort avec beaucoup d'incertitude de de
cette phase de poule Jean vous aussi
vous étiez mitigé oui oui ben oui tout a
été dit là j'aiété mitigé parce que
voilà positif parce qu'il y a la
qualification donc faut pas la bouder
ils sont quand même à 8e de finale la
poule était compliqué euh donc ça c'est
positif après moi je suis désolé mais
c'est la manière quoi après on dit
toujours on trouve toujours les excuses
moi j'estime que quand on quand on
prétend arriver sur le sur le toit de
l'Europe et gagner cette ce coupe aux
grandes oreilles et ben on montre autre
chose et on est un petit peu plus serein
là ils vont en 8e et puis euh benà
maintenant on est en train voilà est-ce
qu'ils vont passer est-ce que est-ce que
c est-ce que là enfin quand même ils ont
des prétentions ils ont des prétention
d'être champion quand on a ces
prétentions là on doit pas on doit pas
être on doit pas être rempli de doute
comme ça c'est pas possible bah la r
sociéade c'est quand même une équipe qui
est 6e du coup de de ligga qui a n'a
perdu que trois matchs cette saison et
ils ont fini premier de leur poule en
Ligue des Champions face à l'Inter
Benfica et salb aussi mais c'est mais de
toute façon c'est pas gagné le souci
c'est c'est ça c'est qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on on est on a cette équipe
du PSG qui devrait être une grosse
équipe européenne et qui finalement ben
plus que jamais ne l'est pas quoi c'està
dire que là on peut pas dire comme l'a
dit Pierre tout à l'heure ils sont loin
être favoris quoi de cette compétition
il y a plus de doute que les saison
dernière les saisons passées je veux
dire pour moi oui pour moi oui
d'ailleurs bon il y a eu quand même
c'est c'est c'est au forceps quoi ce
penalty à la 97e là oui et puis le coach
qui le coach qui trouve pas non plus qui
trouve pas qui trouve pas la bonne
formule non plus hein il change souvent
il trouve moi je trouve
que mal on a du mal à le suivre on a du
mal à le suivre après j'ai envie de dire
que la vraie compétition ça va démarrer
en 8e de finale on le disait c'est une
normalité la qualification alors elle a
été obtenue au forceps mais c'est à
partir des 8è de finale face à la Real
sociéedad qui ne sera pas quand même une
mince à faire ça a été la meilleure
équipe défensive sur les phases de pou
ils ont encaissé deux buts dans une pou
vous l'avez rappel où il y a l'Inter qui
est le dernier finaliste de la Ligue des
champions qui est pas le grandissime
favori mais qui fait partie de ces
quatre C équipes qui peuvent remporter
la Ligue des Champions à la fin de la
saison il finissent devant cette il
finissent devant l'Inter ouais tout à
fait vous êtes persuadé que le PSG va se
qualifier ou pas en quart de finale
quand quand on voit ce tirage quand même
un petit tour de table comme à chaque
fois
grégoryi dis non dis NON je dis non je
dis non mais attention non je dis
attention à la Real socieda et
d'ailleurs alors petite petite anecdote
le PSG va de nouveau jouer le jour de la
à Saint-Valentin donc il y aura
peut-être des amoureux du foot qui
justement jeis dire que ça être très
compliqué pour gen notamment de regarder
le premier match ils avaient pas le
choix dans la date pour ce 8e de final
mais voilà ils joueront du côté du du
Parc des Princes le 14 février il y aura
beaucoup de déçus à mon avis ce second
le second match ce sera le 5 mars en
Espagne Jean vous êtes déçu du coup par
le 14 février
il y aura pas beaucoup de déçu il aura
beaucoup de divorce il aura beaucoup de
divorce il y aura beaucoup le divorce
non mais alors le pronostic ouais
pronostic alors je les vois passer 8e
ouais je les vois passer ok Philippe moi
aussi vous voyz passer oui oui ok on
rortira au cas où s' élimination on
ressortira ce petit moment de l'émission
donc comme greégory l'a dit le PSG
jouera contre la Real Sociedad le 14
février prochain Jean sera peut-être
devant sa télé ou pas on verra et le
retour sera en Espagne le 5 mars vous
préféz une soirée en amoureux plutôt que
une soirée tout fait tout à fait le
message est passé voilà le CH vite fait
on va maintenant parler à box ce samedi
9 décembre Tony Hoka est remonté sur le
ring après deux défaites de rang le
français champion olympique en 2016
affronté le Belge Riyad Merry à Roland
Garos et le boxeur de 31 ans originaire
de Chantou lesvg a été battu au point
par le Belge après sa défaite il a
laissé planer le doute sur la suite de
sa carrière la question sur cette
thématique la carrière de Tony Yoka
est-elle terminée oui ou non oui pour
vous Jean non pour vous Grégory oui pour
vous Philippe et vous êtes partagé
pierre on fait un petit duel entre vous
Jean et et Philippe Jean vous commencez
oh vas-y tu commence vas-y commence ah
ça se fait des courtoisies oui oui oui
oui mais c'est Noël c'est
Noël cadeau par contre cade cade pas de
cadeau allez-y gens donc pour moi alors
pour moi oui pour moi oui parce que là
jamais de donc c'est terminé pour vous
non mais alors
pour moi c'est terminé parce que euh ça
fait trois défaites d'affilé donc là là
le retard est pris l'échéance pour aller
essayer de disputer autre chose c'est
c'est quasiment infaisable et puis
surtout là ben là je commence à me poser
vraiment la la la grande question c'est
est-ce que vraiment Tony Yoka était le
grand champion qu'on a bien voulu faire
faire croire entre guillemets et je
crois que pour ça c'est pas sa faute je
crois que c'est purement français ça on
a pris ce ce sportif on lui a mis une
étiquette dans le dos on a dit ce sera
un grand champion de boxe et je crois
que malheureusement pour lui Ben ce
n'est pas le cas quoi ce n'est pas le
cas parce que encore une fois il a pas
quand même affronté des monstres de la
boxe quoi et il a zéro victoire face à
des concurrents on va dire un petit peu
plus intéressants un petit peu plus un
petit peu plus capé que ce qu'il avait
pu faire jusqu'à présent et je crois que
malheureusement pour lui et ben il est
pas au niveau au haut niveau
international et c'est pour cela que
pour moi ben je crois que ça sa carrière
et ses chances d'obtenir un titre
mondial sont
quasiment quasiment fini pour moi
Philippe qu'est-ce que vous répondez à à
répond rien parce que je lu ai dit que
j'ai pour moi sa carrière est terminée
je veux dire les amateurs de
Boxis ah d'accord jeens je pensais que
n'était pas terminé pour vous non non
j'ai pas changé non non j'ai pas changé
non non j'ai justement c'est que qui
pour vous c'était terminé pour vous
Grégor on va faire on va changer de duel
on va prendre Grégor moi je réponds
purement à votre question sa carrière
est-elle terminée non il lui reste
encore un match avec son contrat dans
dans le cadre de son contrat avec Canal
plus donc sa carrière n'est pas terminée
après si vous aviez posé la question
est-ce que ça met définitivement fin à
ses chances de conquérir un titre
mondial là je vous aurais répondu oui
c'est pas pareil je pense qu'il va lui
rester préciser un peu
plus VO il s non mais il s'est vu que
après après mon intervention il s'est
dit là je peux pas je pe pas je suis
obligé de de me dérober non alors voilà
mais en tout cas il lui reste un contrat
dans dans le cadre de son contrat avec
Canal plus alors c'est vrai que Jean
disait c'est peut-être les Français qui
ont construit peut-être ce ce mythe Yoka
champion olympique capable d'aller
gagner un titre voilà professionnel mais
c'est pas la même chose on parle de box
amateur et de box et de box
professionnel et peut-être qu'on a
construit un peu trop vite ce myth il y
a eu effectivement tout un programme la
conquête qui a été mise en avant par par
Canal Plus pour suivre Tony Yoka dans
dans cette épopée quand il a eu des
adversaires euh à sa portée qui étaiit
même on disait les videurs du Makumba en
rigolant souvent ça ils ont été
présentés comme ça ça lui réussissait
Takam bacolé deux défaites d'affilé face
à ses boxeurs alors qu'ils sont plutôt
sur la fin de leur carrière ils sont pas
à l'apogé de leur carrière mais c'était
des adversaires quand même de plus haut
rang pour pour Tony Yoka et euh il a
échoué face à ses deux adversaires là ce
qui est plus surprenant c'est qu'il
avait en face de lui Riad Mary qui qui a
un Belge qui en plus je crois qu'il a 10
cm de moins que que lui est plus petit
de 10 cm même lui il était pas confiant
avant le début de son combat il était
pas confiant là on se disait que cétait
un adversaire largement à sa'pporter et
finalement bah il il a échoué alors il y
a plusieurs clés d'analyse est-ce que
Yoka a une pression supplémentaire lui
qui sortait de de défaites d'affilé face
à son public puis que puisque c'était à
à Roland Garros on a quand même le
sentiment que c'est un boxeur qui
n'arrive pas à exprimer totalement son
talent dans les dans les grandes
rencontres et on a l'impression qui qui
retient ses coups qui euh euh voilà
quand il est poussé dans la difficulté
il arrive il n'arrive pas à changer de
niveau à élever son rythme donc ça c'est
des vraies lacunes dans la dans la boxe
professionnelle et ce qui est inquiétant
oui c'est l'état psychologique je pense
qu'il était déjà assez touché après ces
deux défaites face à à Takam et et
bacolé là on va le récupérer je sais pas
dans dans quel état Tony Tony Yoka
peut-être que la solution ce serait
d'aller faire un combat à l'étranger
pour essayer de s'éloigner un peu de
cette pression médiatique en en France
donc ça n'est pas terminé lui reste des
combats maintenant pour moi c'estes Chan
de décrocher un titre mondial là oui on
peut on peut faire un tra c'est
impossible Pierre Chevalier impossible
pour vous euh moi moi j'ai moi j'étais
j'étais
mitigé il y a deux raisons la première
c'est le contexte général dans lequel il
fait ses combats et deuxièmement c'est
la manière contexte grégoryi l'a rappelé
il était à domicile à Roland
Garros dans un dans un combat qui
contenu comparé aux deux premiers quand
on parle de quand on passe de de bacolé
à Takam et Takam ài c'est c'est là le
normalement c'était largement à
s'apporter c'estàd qu'en gros la la
qualité la qualité des boxeurs est allée
en décroissant sur ce trème combat là il
en reste un 4e donc d'accord avec
gregoryi c'est il reste encore cette
partie là si si canal honore bien on
aura bien cette partie du contrat parce
que ça a pas forcément fait recette non
plus ni ni ni dans dans la salle ni ni à
la ni à la télé en fait en gros et je
parlais de la de la manière l'impression
que l'effervescence autour de
tonyok voilà c'est c'est le c'est le ça
faitch ça c'est le le soufflet qui
retombe un peu et pour une raison de
manière sur le combat qu' le combat le
dernier combat il était il était passif
il il a été exhorté par ses entraîneur
de pouvoir tirer profit de son allonge
effectivement il avait il lu rendait son
lui rendait facile facile 20 30 cm et
donc normalement normalement avec
l'allonge l'allonge de yok c'est quand
même c'est quand même un athlète qui se
pose là en en terme de carure physique
il n'en a pas tiré profit c'està-dire
que là c'est vraiment une passivité
peut-être comme comme le disait Greg de
ne pas être capable d'être au
rendez-vous sur ces sur ces gros ces
grosses réunions et et ce qui nous fait
dire et et là et ce qui nous fait
regretter regretter chialer chialer
limite parce que c'était très prometteur
oui il y a une vraie la différence entre
le entre un titre de champion olympique
en amateur et puis et puis un et puis un
combat professionnel mais qui qui nous
fait regretter les promesses les
promesses qu'on évoquait au départ quand
quand Tony Yoka s'est frotté à la une
carrière professionnelle pour aller
chercher une ceinture une ceinture chez
les lourd et qui qui s'éloigne de plus
en plus donc il reste ce fameux match
donc la carrière a priori n'est pas
terminée mais là là en gros les les les
espoirs de titre s'envolent s'envolent
quand même de plus en plus et sont plus
en plus hypoé
problème mental peut-être Philippe volac
c'est un peu surprendant moi je l'ai vu
en différé parce que en plus ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que le combat avait lieu
en même temps qu'un match du PSG au Parc
des Princes et c'était à Roland Garos
c'est c'est aussi bizarre c'est aussi
bizarre tu vois je TR en programmation
c'est quand même c'est quand même
bizarre et le match de le match de
mêmeeur et le match du PSG été
retransmis aussi par Canal plus c'est ça
aussi he et par rapport à son interview
qu'il a eu avant il dit vous allez voir
j'ai changé depuis 2 ans je me suis là
je me suis rem mis en en cause et tout
vous allez voir tout voir dès le premier
round bah on na rien vu il était trop
timide passif comme tu as dit aussi
passif il y a eu un comment un un
comment je veux dire les amateurs de box
63 % qui qui disent qu'il est qu'il est
surcôté et les 47 % qu'il est qui disent
comme ça qu'il est prétentieux ça veut
tout dire c'est des amateurs de box qui
disent ça quand même he je veux dire
donc et je me dis il faut penser aussi
que bien sûr qu'il a été bon amateur
mais quand on pense en 2016 aux Jeux
Olympiques tout le monde a dit que il
avait été très très avantagé sur tout
par l'arbitrage donc voilà
donc Jean très rapidement oui très
rapidement non je pense pas qu'il soit
prétentieux je pense pas du tout que so
prétentieux oui oui un sage pour ma part
non non pour ma part je pense pas que
c'est c'est de la prétention je pense
plutôt que ce ce ce sportif ce grand
sportif n'a pas eu le choix et et qu' on
l'a poussé on l'a poussé et j'ai lu un
petit article dans l'équipe du président
de la Ligue nationale de boxe
professionnelou exact qui déclare je
crois que c'est dolpierre je crois
dolpierre dolpierre Roben dolpierre qui
déclare qu'il aurait quand même aimé
aimer voir un arbitrage maison en
favorable à Yoka sur ce combat alors là
je là là je me dis quand même il est
quand même président de la ligue la
Ligue nationale
profession mais ça ne m'étonne pas mais
c'est c'est bien la preuve qu'il y a
certaines personnes qui qui ont voulu
faire de Yoka un grand champion
sans vraiment par exemple lui demander
peut-être son avis on a dit toi tu seras
un champion on va s'occuper de toi et je
crois que malheureusement pour lui et
encore une fois je le dis et ce n'est
pas le
cas ça ça montre aussi que ce monde de
la boxe professionnelle est assez cruel
et que ça joue aussi à rien mais ça
c'est vrai je pense dans le dans le
sport professionnel il y a moins d'un an
Yoka aurait pu être le challenger du
champion du monde USIC finalement le
combat n'avait pas eu lie parce qu'il
s'était déjà engagé sur un un combat
face à à Martin Bacolet qui je disais
tout à l'heure alors c'était Takam qui
plus âgé que Yoka Martin bacolé un peu
plus jeune que que Tony Yoka finalement
ça joue peut-être à rien parce qu'à ce
moment-là il était en confiance s'il
faisait face il était challenger USI on
sait pas quelle aurait été l'issue du
combat finalement il est resté sur cette
frustration et depuis il y a eu trois
défaites en sachant que le combat avec
Martin Bacolet était dans un premier
temps annulé et il a fait valoir une
clause pour faire ce combat et du coup
le combat avec uzik n'a pas pu se
dérouler à cause de cette fameuse clause
alors que tonyoka voulait voulait aller
sur ce combat là contre contre usque et
pourquoi pas un titre de champion du
monde un petit mot voulez dire FIP non
non non tout tout a bien été dit on va
voir un peu le 4e combat s'il a lieu et
après on va voir un peu ça va être un
tournant il est pas il est pas si si
vieux que ça en plus donc et normalement
il est encore mais bon c'est moi je
pense que c'est difficile parce que là
je pense que on a vu son interview après
match là il était vraiment dépité et au
fond du trou vraiment par
rapport même par rapport à ses autres
combats où il éta plus VO là il était
vraiment je l'ai trouvé vraiment dépit
au fond du trou là ouais on continuera
évidemment à suivre Tony yok on espère
que livelinois continuera quand même la
boxe parce qu'on aime parler de Tony
Yoka ici sur ce plateau on va maintenant
passer à l'envolet de Grégory la
dernière de l'année c'est un petit peu
notre dessert à chaque fois dans cette
dans cette émission alors de quoi
allez-vous nous parler Grégory
aujourd'ui les suiveurs de si on parles
sport en ont l'habitude pour la dernière
émission de l'année c'est l'occasion
pour nous de remettre nos bons points
désignés le sportif yvelinois de l'année
alors je vais vous donner quelques-unes
de mes préférences alors que Philip est
en train de changer de de tenue pendant
mon envolet mes préférences elles sont
nombreuses en 2023 beaucoup d'athlètes
se sont distingué et vous le savez mon
sport de prix d'élection c'est le
football l'an passé j'avais jeté mon
dévolu sur la performance collective du
Football Club de Versailles et bien
cette année dans ma présélection je
place Kyan mppé qui d'autres 25 ans
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs au moment on
enregistre cette émission bon
anniversaire à lui il a terminé son
année 2022 éventuellement si s'il
regarde cette émission en peut nous
appeler sil veut s'il veut intervenir il
avait terminé on l'avait laissé l'année
dernière en 2022 avec un triplé en
finale de la Coupe du Monde 2022 rien
que ça et depuis janvier kiki n'a pas
déçu individuellement au contraire de
son club le pariss sa-germain meilleur
buteur de la saison dernière avec 29
buts en Ligue 1 celui qui a été formé à
l'INF claire fontaine à remporter le
championnat le 11e titre de son club
c'est un record pour le championnat de
France et c'est son 6e titre de champion
de France dans sa carrière
professionnelle depuis août il a
continué sur cette lancée puisquil a
déjà inscrit 16 buts en Ligue 1 il est
bon leader avec beaucoup de buts
d'avance dans ce classement débeurs en
en Ligue 1 mais sa place au sa trème
place nous un problème de caméra
décidément aujourd'hui aujourd'hui voilà
c'est il y y a de d'né la fê de fin
d'année la la caméra une des caméras est
tombé on espère qu'elle n'a pas eu trop
mal cette caméra donc je disais sa
troisème place au Ballon d'Or pour Kyan
Mbappé derrière Lyonel Messi derrière
herling alland a pu lui laisser c'est
sûr un goût amer alors 2023 c'est aussi
l'occasion de confirmer des talents au
skyping de voisin le bretonux on a une
pépite de 23 ans qui pourrait briller
lors des prochains Jeux paralympiques
luci ha tiers titré en double et 2e à
l'Open de Taiwan dont la parapongiste
est revenue avec cinq médailles s'est
classé 3e lors du ski paratté grand
tournoi international de tennis de table
and dis sport qui se déroule au
Vélodrome national à côté c'est aussi
une ambassadrice de son sport elle fait
partie du dispositif champion 2024 qui
est mise en place par le Département des
evvlin elle y parle de son sport et
aussi du handicap auprès des jeunes
alors dans les evvlin aussi on a un club
qui truste les premières places
mondiales ces athlètes ont de vraies
chances de briller au prochain JO de
Paris ils ont d'ailleurs ramené la
première médaille de l'histoire pour la
France de la discipline lors des
derniers Jeux à Tokyo ce club c'est
poissi triathlon elle c'est dommage à
quitté l'équipe cette année Cassandre
breugrand mais son année 2023 a été
belle on parle ici de la numéro 2
mondial du triathlon sur la saison à 26
ans Cassandre Beaugrand est désormais
vice-championne du monde la sportive
s'est classé 3e lors de la grande finale
du World triathlon Championship Series
en Espagne 2e du Test Event à Paris a
remporté les étapes d'Hambourg et
Sunderland l'été prochain elle espère
briller à domicile tout comme lui Dorian
Coninx 29 ans qui s'apprête tout comme
Cassandre Beaugrand à participer à ses
3è Jos le triathlète est allé encore
plus loin que sa compatriote cette année
puisque lui est devenu champion du monde
Dorian a conquis ce premier titre après
une ultime étape magnifique lors du wtcs
à Pontevedra en Espagne le pisiqueet a
faim c'est le cas de le dire et après
des déceptions individuelles lors des
derniers Jeux Olympiques cette fois-ci
il a toutes ses chances de décrocher une
médaille d'or olympique à Paris depuis
tout à l'heure on parle d'individu je
veux rendre aussi hommage aux équipes et
la performance collective vivelinoise de
l'année et sans conteste celle des
coupgardes de Montini le bretonne
l'équipe de baseball a remporté en mai
dernier son premier challenge de France
et en face des ivelinois ce n'était pas
une mince affaire ceétait pas un mince
adversaire les huskis de rouan tenant du
titre et les hommes du président José
des harjo sont all les même plus plus
loin CEC pour la deuxième fois de leur
histoire en finale du championnat de
France ça n'était arrivé qu'une seule
fois en 2018 et malheureusement l'issue
a été à la même une défaite contre les
barracouas de Montpellier bravo à eux
tout de même et ça s'est joué sur le
dernier match ça s'est joué sur le match
numéro 5 effectivement pour les cougard
alors la palme du sport le plus original
je la remets à Muriel beauvillin sa
discipline le culturisme naturel
autrement dit la musculation sans l'aide
de produits dopan à 51 ans cet habit
habitante de mytinville s'est adjugé
trois titres de championne univers en
Corée du Sud elle concourait dans quatre
épreuves Muriel bovvillin c'est aussi un
parcours de ville ivlinoise a débuté le
culturisme naturel il y a seulement 3
ans ce sport l'a aidé à vaincre une
dépression et à se dépasser suite à un
drame familial on arrive tranquillement
mais sûrement vers la fin de cette
envolée alors qui est le sportif
yvelinois de l'année deux athlètees pour
moi ce départage se distingue et et vous
allez justement m'aider à les départager
il se distingue vous allez m'aider à les
à départager alors lui d'abord a écrasé
la concurrence dans le monde de la
natation alors pour les Jeux Olympiques
la France à Léon marchand mais pour les
Jeux paralympiques les Français les
ivelinois ont Alex Portal le nageur de
Saint-Germain enline a que 21 ans mais
ça ne l'a pas empêché de gagner qu
médaill d'or quatre médailles dont trois
en or au mondiaux à Manchester cet été
lors des derniers championnats de France
l'ivelinois a battu non pas un non pas
deux non pas trois mais six records du
monde sur ces championnats de France le
tout sur 7p épreuv disputé donc SEP
épreuves disputées six records du monde
pour Alex Portal rien que ça on parle là
d'un extraterrestre de sa discipline
Alex Portal ne se cache d'ailleurs pas
après l'argent et le bronze à Tokyo
c'est bien l'or paralympique qu'il vise
à Paris 2024 et puisqu'on parle d'Alien
on va finir avec un autre alien que ce
soit pour le talent la précocité pour
les dimensions il en a un il a 19 ans
2,24 ou 26 si on prend en compte les
chaussures une pointure 56 je parle bien
sûr c'est facile ça s'est affiché à
l'écrananama tatata voilà suspense celui
qui a débuté le basket à l'entente le
chîn et Versailles a été l'attraction
mondiale de cette année 2023 drafté en
première position en NBA direction les
Spurs de santonio pour devenir pourquoi
pas une légende du basket c'est tout le
mal qu'on lui souhaite avant de partir
pour les États-Unis WBI avait déjà
brillé dans le championnat de bcilick
élite en France il avait é claboussé ce
championnat de France de son talent
finaliste avec les M92 il a été titré de
de la distinction de MVP de la saison
mais aussi celui de meilleur défenseur
meilleur jeune meilleur marqueur
meilleur rebondeur meilleur contreur
meilleur tout voilà puisqu'il a éé il a
été MVP de cette LNB fortune diverse en
NBA pour le moment car les Spurs sont
très mal débutés actuel dernier de la
Conférence Ouest avec 22 défaites en 26
matchs il a eu un record historique de
18 défaites d'affilé pour les Spurs
alors W brille tout de même
individuellement ses performances
individuelles on l'espère pourrait lui
permettre de décrocher le titre de
Rookie de l'année c'est pas encore gagné
parce que de l'autre côté collectivement
les Spurs ne sont pas au rendez-vous
voilà messieurs faites vos choix quel
que soit votre préférence je crois qu'on
peut le dire encore 2023 a était une
très belle année sportive avec de de
belles performances pour nos athlètes
bravo belle envolé grégoryi la dernière
de l'année 2023 bravo à vous beaucoup de
présélectionnés on avait discuté de ça
en en off beaucoup
il y a du talent dans les il y a du
talent euh quel est votre Evely l'année
autour de cette table on a vu que
greégory pour Grégoris son cœur balance
entre alexort on va dire au niveau des
titres sportifs c'est Alex Portal parce
que quand même quatre médailles trois en
or mais on va dire au niveau médiatique
au niveau du symbole c'est quand même
Victor wanama il a il a marqué cette
année à mon avis donc en gros vous allez
lui remettre une coupe quelque chose
comme ça éventuellement il peut venir
sur
plmission pour récupérer oui il peut
récupérer cette coupe en tout cas ici
sur le
plateau s'il entend le message euh
pierre pour vous c'est qui moi je dirais
que je favoriseraiis des sports un peu
moins médiatiques justement parce que je
pense que Victor waniama on va en parler
en reparler dans les années à venir et
que là sur une année olympique peoster
les 10 places de sportifinis l'année sur
les 10es Ann a sans doute besoin d'un
petit peu plus de projecteur sur des
disciplines un petit peu plus discrètes
donc je dirais Cassandre sur le le le
triathlon et
Etex sur sur le paralympique parce que
au-delà au-delà de ses performances hors
norme on a besoin que les je les Jeux
paralympiques de Paris soient aussi
successful et aussi populaire et
peut-être aussi aussi performant pour
l'équipe de France pour les équipes de
France que les les Jeux Olympiques
Philippe pour vous moi les deux spor les
de les deuxffiche sont c'est difficile à
départager he parce que c'est quand même
très fort aussi en natation c'est quand
même c'est quand même très fort après
marchand c'est quand même en en
paraompique c'est très fort
et marchand c'est
chez dire oui et com dire c'est c'est à
peu près
l'équivalent on dit que Alex Portel
c'est le Léon marchand de la
natation non mais les deux sont les deux
ont fait on fait une belle une belle
année une très très belle année donc
c'est difficile c'est bon les deux c'est
c'est sport aussi individuel mais bon
j'ai du mal à départager départager les
deux si vous deviez voter quand même je
ferai pour la natation pour la natation
par anatation ouais avec Alex Portal
pour vous Jean et alors moi je vais vous
dire moi pour moi c'est Victor banem
parce que c'est un garçon qu'on
attendait qu'on attendait qu'on se
disait voilà est-ce qu'il va y arriver
et il explose tous les compteurs dans
une équipe où le collectif n'est pas
spécialement au rendez-vous et où il a
pas il a pas réellement de quoi
s'exprimer pleinement avec ses ses ses
compatriotes du terrain mais quand même
individuellement c'est quand même un
phénomène c'est le phénomène qu'on
attendait
et cocorico c'est un français il est
là-bas il va devenir un grand parce que
là maintenant on peut le dire pas
simplement par la taille et les
dimensions mais ça va être un grand
basketeur c'est certain donc donc pour
moi c'est le sportif de l'année c'est
pas trop tôt parce que je pense qu'on
peut l'avoir l'année prochaine l'année
d'après l'année d'encore après peuttre
on l'attendait tellement parce que on
était quand même dans dans l'attente
est-ce qu'il va s'acclimater est-ce que
vraiment c'est vraiment le grand
champion qu'on attend puisque là c'est
le la barre la plus haute la NBA et
c'est individuellement un grand joueur
quoi voilà on attendait donc mais on a
la preuve les statistiques sont là il il
fait que il fait que grandir encore une
fois dans une équipe qui ne gagne pas
c'est encore plus difficile c'est encore
plus compliqué parce que il faut dire
que ce ce ce joueur là il serait dans
une équipe avec avec quatre autres
joueurs dans dans une grosse équipe de
la NBA je pense qu' il exploserait il
exploserait tout le monde quoi donc donc
je dis bravo et pour moi c'est le
sportif un contesté de l'année et
l'année prochaine il participera
sûrement aux Jeux olympiques de Paris
2024 donc ça sera peut-être l'occasion
de le rilir sportif yvelinois de l'année
on va maintenant passer à notre page
[Musique]
débat je vous propose dans cette page
débat de revenir sur les moments forts
qui ont rythmé les evelines en 2023 on
commence par le Paris Brest Paris en
août dernier des milliers de cyclistes
sont partis de rambouiller à vélo ils
sont venus de toute la France ils ont
parcouru 1200 km cette compétition a
lieu tous les 4 ans ils sont venus de la
France et même du monde entier alors
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
compétition messieurs très rapidement en
fait je vais vous en proposer plusieurs
et on fait un petit tour de table à
chaque fois qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
cette compétition j'aime pas le
vélo pas plus que ça je connaissais non
je et très honnêtement je ne connaissais
pas cette connaissais plus le gâteau oui
voilà moi c'est la pâtisserie mais c'est
lié c'est lié c'est lié effectivement la
pâtisserie a été créée à l'occasion d'un
Paris la pâtisserie par enfin pâtissier
de maison la fite ou à l'époque où
c'était encore une compétition cycliste
puisque maintenant elle a évolué vers
une formule randhonneur ou cyclotourisme
en tout cas c'est une tradition qui se
perdure il y a plus la grande
compétition qui a pu avoir jusque dans
les années 50 mais une tradition qui se
qui perdure dans le temps et et qui
perdure aussi la légende du Paris Brest
de de cette pâtisserieac très rapidement
vous aimez bien ouais c'est la crème
de
voilà on va vous garder en 2024 Philippe
on va vous garder Jean vous en pensez
quoi Paris Brest ouais ouais c'est bien
qui
continue alors deuxième événement
c'était les 9F et 10 décembre dernier
les championnats de France de BMX
Freestyle étaient organisé au Vélodrome
national de 5tin en ieline le
rendez-vous a attiré des milliers de
fans et des sportifs qui vont
représenter la France pendant les
prochains jeux olympiques il y avait au
total 90 sportifs pareil qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de cette compétition Jean
ben il y a plus vous qui êtes un fan de
sport urbain oui oui il y a plus de
compétiteurs que de public ah non quand
même il y avait du monde il y avait du
monde il y avait à peu près 2000
oui c'est bien qui
continue Philippe vous aimez bien aussi
les sports extrêmes pas plus que ça pas
plus que ça pas plus que ça au niveau
même des Jeux Olympiques il y a des
choses que il y a des disciplines que
j'aurais mis j'aurais mis plutôt à la
place comme le par exemple on va pas
dire mais le karaté par exemple qui est
pas et j'aurais mis d'abord et il y a
d'autres disciplines voilà mais bon vous
êtes pas très fan vous êtes pas très fan
Gregory non mais ça permet de voir le
vélodrome dans une autre configuration
alors il y a la piste de BMX Race à
l'extérieur là on a mis à l'honneur le
freestyle on a pu utiliser cette a
central et montrer que le vélodrome
pouvait accueillir tout type d'événement
là c'est un événement purement cycliste
c'est sa vocation première mais ça a
permis de voir une belle discipline qui
qui sera au JO pour le BMX Freestyle
pierre rapidement même si c'est du vélo
je trouve ça plus spectaculaire et plus
plus oui je je préfère et je trouve je
trouve ça plus fun bon vous qui adorez
en tout cas le vélo he il y a eu
également le Parisis en mars 2023 la
Course au Soleil est partie depuis les
evelines pour la 14e fois consécutive la
course est partie depuis l'avrière et le
lendemain depuis bazinville il y avait
pogachar et vingegard au départ cette
année qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de
cette compétition Philippe très bien
c'est une bonne une bonne pub pour les
Yvelines pour des petites vill en plus
c'est ce que on en avait parlé dans
cette année je veux dire quand on mais
c'est une bonne pub pour les petites
villes comme la verrière et basinville
c'est ça ouais je trouve que c'est c'est
c'est très bien il a toujours une grosse
commune et un petit village le lendemain
qui sont qui sont choisis Jean qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez vous parisce vous
aimez bien vous Paris I c'est j'aime
bien parinis oui oui c'est c'est très
joli et c'est un petit tour de France
voilà et c'est très bien en plus parce
que chaque année ça
parttit côté desin donc prochaine départ
depuis les mur le lendemain depuis la
petite commune de Toir ah oui il
faudrait pas qu'il qu'il s'échappe dans
le zo ça sera devant le zo euh Grégory
bah sans être réducteur vous avez parlé
des des deux noms principaux vingegord
et pogar pogar qui s'est imposé sur sur
sparenis c'est la première fois depuis
nombreuses années qu'on avait les deux
derniers vainqueurs du Tour de France et
ils étaient à la verrière et bazinville
donc je pense qu'on que les amateurs
cyclistes ont pris leurs pieds alors il
y a eu aussi le Tour de France 2023 la
dernière étape est partie depuis le
vélodrome national de 50 ans en juillet
dernier alors on a pu voir le vainqueur
Jonas
vingegard dans cette terre centrale du
Vélodrome national de de 50 an on le
voit avec son petit maillot jaune alors
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez c'est un
bel événement ça par contre par contre
je ne sais pas mais pour pour le
cyclisme en tout cas oui oui année année
année olympique qui plusé ça met ça met
en valeur un des sites olympiques de
Paris 2024 et et trèv de plaisanterie
comme direa un lapin euh je je respecte
quand même les classiques et là en
l'occurrence Paris Paris Nice et Tour de
France ce sont des ce sont des très très
grands événements sportifs c'est pas
c'est pas Maam mais
c'est c'est un très bel événement
sportif et en plus quand il quand il
prend part dans les evelines comme on a
comme on a plaisir à le rappeler c'est
encore mieux Philipp moi très bien je
trouve ça vraiment très bien que ça
parte du Vélodrome en plus comme l'a dit
Pierre une année l'année comment enfin
des Jeux Olympiques moi je trouve que
c'est c'est très bien ça met en lumière
en plus plus le le Vélodrome c'est mieux
que le
BMX gens il AC du vélo il a beaucoup de
vélo dans les zbine comme vous pouvez le
voir des gros événements sportifé terre
de vélo c'est très très souvent quand on
parle grand événements sportif dans
lesbin on parle vélo oui c'est vrai non
mais c'est très bien le Tour de France
c'est la plus grande compétition
cyclisme du mondeor non tout a été dit
ça clôturit encore une très belle
édition du Tour de
France on va pas parler vélo pour une
fois il y a aussi le CrossFit avec le
CrossFit throwown
2023 800 sportifs et 9000 personnes se
sont donné rendez-vous au Vélodrome
national de 50 ans en Ilin ouis oui on
peut le voir ils ils ils ont donné ils
ont donné vraiment beaucoup de choses
sur sur cette terre centrale du
Vélodrome et aussi à l'extérieur c'était
très impressionnant ils ont fait cette
compétition sur 3 jours une petite
réaction autour de de cette table Jean
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous c'est
ça ça voie ça envoie ça envoie du gaz là
attention ça a dû ça a dû transpirer sec
hein bel événement Philippe
ouais bel événement un pe hein il y a
pas que du vélo vélo nation on entend
parler beaucoup hein des des salles des
salles de CrossFit et on entend il y en
a beaucoup qui en font qui en font hein
donc c'est en plein boom c'est en plein
boom mais c'est impressionnant au niveau
de la force pierre Chali vous on vous a
pas euu dans dans sur sur
la avait av vraiment une très très
grosse machine sur laquelle que j'ai
explosé d'ailleurs et euh c'est c'est
c'est une mode le le CrossFit c'est une
mode qui dure dans l'aspect sport santé
donc pratiquer régulièrement une une
activité physique c'est une des plus
faciles entre guillemets à à pratiquer
parce que maintenant des des agrs de
sport de CrossFit on en trouve un peu
partout dans les villes maintenant dans
les centres-villes et ça ça s'organise
en bande ça se ça se challenge un petit
peu justement alors ça se regarde
beaucoup oui mais je je trouve que c'est
c'est une une très bonne chose de donner
cette occasion
là à tout le monde de pouvoir faire du
sport et donc là de de mettre en lumière
certaines belles compétitions greégory
très rapidement parce qu'on est très en
T dans l'émission non juste pour dire
c'était l'un des premiers événements
post crise covid au Vélodrome cet
événement CrossFit et c'est un événement
qui commence à s'installer et ça nous a
montré qu'il y avait encore beaucoup de
travail pour nous je pense alors de la
natation aussi en mars dernier le Giant
open le nouveau rendez-vous de la
natation é organisée à la piscine de
saint-jele il y a eu des têtes
d'affiches comme Charlotte Bonet ou
encore Maxime grous
rendez-vous qui devait revenir qui
devrait revenir l'année prochaine à
saintg peut-être même dans les années
les prochaines années qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez pareil très rapidement je vais
peut-être faire juste un mini tour de
table Philippe vous en pensez quoi ça
embrasse bien ouais très très bien vous
allez vous allez vraiment rester sur
cette année
gen'est font
dans minute
papillon c'était bien oui cé non mais
c'est bien c'est bien ça va c'est
alors on reste à saint-g manl là aussi
il y a eu une grosse compétition le
championnat de France de bras de fer
organisé par la Fédération Française de
force il étaient environ 170
participants à se défier dans plusieurs
catégories et selon l'âge et le poids
pareil une petite réaction autour de de
cette table sur cette compétition de
bras de fer c'est c'est très
spectaculaire c'est très j'ta je j' on
le faisait j'en faisais Brou ou oua fais
du bras à la y a du sport il a de la
espoir Gregori non mais c'est non c'est
c'est le sport et c'est insolite ça ça
fait du bien d'avoir aussi des des
événements de cette sor là de cette
manière peut-être que ça reviendra dans
les dans les Prain Ann concours de claqu
comme ça enfin en basket il y a eu le
match de basket entre les lycées
versaill et saintjeuneviève et hoch le
16 février dernier au gymnase maoboron
l'ambiance était incroyable et c'est
Ginette qui l'a emporté qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de cette compétition ce ce
derby ce duel qui nous passionne ici sur
ce plateau excellent excellent événement
très populaire vraiment fun seul bémol
c'est que ça souffre la comparaison par
rapport à la NCAA et à des compétitions
universitaires américaines mais
continuons ça ça ça draine ça draine un
public et un enthousiasme dingue Grégor
vous qui étiez sur place c'était déjà ma
deuxè pour ce match non non match qui à
mon avis commence à gagner en popularité
alors ça reste un événement pour
l'instant fer mais pourquoi pas un jour
le voir ouvert au public dans une plus
grosse structure vous aimez Philippe
volac
ouais c'est là non c'est Ginette la
perfection masculin c'est pas
rasoir bon la question sur cette
thématique la question sur cette
thématique pour vous un petit tour de
table très rapide quel est le meilleur
événement de 2023 dans les ielines très
rapidement Grégory vous prenez non moi
j'ai bien aimé alors on vous l'z pas
cité mais le test even sur la la colline
d'lancour qui était un événement
préparatoire pour les Jeux Olympiques et
ça nous a permis de rentrer dans cette
dernière ligne droite qui va nous
conduire à l'été 2024 Jean l'événement
préféré de cette année 203 Tour de
France Tourance Philippe moi aussi
départ de la dernière étape du Tour de
France ça va vous étonner moi parisce
Paris Nice parisce
pourquoi voilà Paris SPR contradiction
et la tradition la tradition du départ
dans les ivelines et et justement cette
mise en valeur des petits petit village
comme des grandes villeses c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission on a même dépassé
au niveau du temps on va terminer comme
d'habitude par une citation aujourd'hui
je vous propose une citation de l'un des
sportifs ivelinois de l'année Victor
wembanama la future pépite du basket
mondiale il faut réussir de grosses
actions pour éteindre ses adversaires je
vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
passz de très bonnes fête sur tv78 à
[Musique]
bientôt